FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ADVISOR HAS BEEN SUCKED INTO
ALL OF THIS.
SAT DOWN WITH MUELLER
INVESTIGATORS AND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
MICHAEL, YOU SAID RECENTLY
IN ANOTHER VIEW YOU BECAME
AWARE WHEN YOU WERE WORKING
ON THE CAMPAIGN DURING 2016
OF ANOTHER POTENTIAL SPY
WORKING ON BEHALF OF INTEL
OR LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
CONTROLLED BY OBAMA.
TELL US WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT
THAT.
>> I HAVE DISCUSSED PUBLICLY
THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS
EARLY MAY APPROACH TO ME BY
A FORMER GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTOR IN THE NATIONAL
SECURITY ARENA WHO THROUGH
AN INTERMEDIARY TRIED TO GET
TO ME AND TELL ME THAT THE
NSA HAD HILLARY CLINTON'S
EMAILS AND THAT WE COULD GET
AHOLD OF THEM IF WE WANTED
THEM.
AND THIS CONVERSATION
CONTINUED FOR A COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
AND I EVENTUALLY TOLD THEM I
HAD NO INTEREST BECAUSE I
THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL AS A
FORMER ARMY VETERAN WHO HELD
A TOP SECRET CLEARANCE I
KNEW THAT WAS FRAUGHT WITH
PERIL.
>> Tucker: YOU BELIEVE THAT
WAS A TRAP TO LURE YOU IN TO
COMPROMISING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IN SOME WAY.
>> I WILL TELL YOU WHAT,
TUCKER, FOR TWO YEARS I
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT IT AS.
I GAVE IT TO THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATORS
WHEN I SAT WITH THEM TWO
WEEKS AGO OR THREE WEEKS
AGO.
AND THEY DIDN'T SEEM THE
LEAST BIT INTERESTED.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO THINK
OF IT.
TWO YEARS I SCRATCHED MY
HEAD.
THE INTERMEDIARY OLD FRIEND
OF MINE.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT OVER
DINNER DOZENS OF TIMES.
WE COULDN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT
IT WAS.
THEN THE NEWS CAME OUT ABOUT
THE SPY LATCHING ON TO
MEMBERS MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN POLICY COMMITTEE.
A LIGHT BULB CAME ON IN MY
HEAD.
IF THIS WASN'T A DANGLE OF
SOME SORT FROM WHATEVER FBI,
WHATEVER THIS WAS STRAKE
ENOUGH WHERE YOU NEEDED TO
BRING IT TO THE PUBLIC.
I KNEW THE INVESTIGATORS
WEREN'TED
WEREN'T INTERESTED IN IT.
THEY AT THIS POINT IN TIME
TAKE NOTES WHEN I TOLD THEM
ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: MAY I STOP YOU
THERE REALLY QUICK?
I'M CONFUSED BY THAT.
THAT'S PRETTY CLOSE TO THE
HEART OF THE TOPIC THAT
MUELLER IS PURPORTEDLY
INVESTIGATING.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: CONSUMING ALL
THIS MONEY AND ATTENTION
INVESTIGATING.
WHY WOULD THEY NOT BE
INTERESTED IN HEARING MORE
ABOUT THAT?
>> RIGHT.
IF THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAD
HILLARY'S EMAILS IN EARLY
MAY WHEN THIS GOVERNMENT
CONTRACTOR WAS TELL US WE
COULD GET THEM WHY AREN'T
THEY INTERESTED.
I HAVE GOT TO TELL YOU
THAT'S WHAT SET OFF A RED
FLAG FOR ME.
THEY DIDN'T SEEM THE LEAST
BIT INTERESTED AT ALL.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN TAKE NOTES.
I OFFERED THEM THE TIME LINE
I WAS READING FROM IN MY
VIEW AND THEY DIDN'T TAKE
IT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
REMARKABLE.
WE HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING YOUR
PERSONAL STORY FOR A NUMBER
OF MONTHS NOW.
AND YOU GOT SUCKED INTO
THIS, I THINK, AND IT'S
TURNED YOUR LIFE UPSIDE
DOWN.
DO YOU EXPECT TO HAVE MORE
CONTACT WITH MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATORS?
>> I BROUGHT THIS TO THE
PUBLIC JUST IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS.
THERE IS ANOTHER APPROACH TO
ME THAT WAS CON IN LATE MAY
OR THE LAST HALF OF MAY
BYSON WHO
BYSOMEWHO
BYSOMEBOO
BYSOMEBODY I BELIEVE WAS
ORGANIZED BY THE
INVESTIGATORS.
I CAN'T TALK ABOUT IT ON
TELEVISION BECAUSE THE
MUELLER TEAM WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT IT SO MUCH SO MUCH
THAT THEY SOUNDED LIKE THE
AUTHORS OF IT.
I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THAT
WITH THE DOJ OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
NOW THAT THAT I KNOW THEY
ARE RESPONDING TO THE
PRESIDENT POSITIVELY AND
LOOKING INTO THESE DANGLES
IN FRONT OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, I WANT TOE TALK
ABOUT BOTH
IBOUT BOTH
I WUT BOTH
I WAN BOTH
I WANT OTH
I WANT TOH
I WANT TO TALKABOUT BOTH OF THE.
ONE I TALKED ABOUT IN PUBLIC
THE FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
GOVERNMENT CONTRACTOR WHO
CAME TO ME THROUGH
INTERMEDIARY IN THE FIRST
WEEK OF MAY AND THIS OTHER
APPROACH THAT HAPPENED IN
THE LAST HALF OF MAY.
MY ATTORNEY IS WRITING A
LETTER TO THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL ASKING TO
BE INVITED TO TESTIFY ON
THIS.
>> Tucker: I HOPE YOU WILL
BE.
BECAUSE, UNLIKE MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATORS, I AM
INTERESTED.
MICHAEL, THANK YOU.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> I WILL TELL YOU, TUCKER,
YOU SEE THESE FBI AGENTS
THAT WANT TO GO IN AS WELL.
THEY ARE ASKING FOR
SUBPOENAS SO THEY CAN GO AND
TALK TO THE IG ABOUT WHAT
THEY SAW SITTING IN THE
OFFICE AT THE FBI.
THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT MEN
AND WOMEN WHO ARE LYING
AGENTS AT THE FBI WHO WANT
TO TALK.
I WANT THEM TO KNOW IF THEY
ARE WATCHING THEY DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT FOR A SUBPOENA, I
KNOW THOSE LEGAL FEES ARE
REALLY EXPENSIVE.
OUR LEGAL FUND AT CAPUTO
LEGAL FEE.COM WILL PAY THEIR
LEGAL FEES.
GO TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
AND SAY WHAT HAPPENED.
WE WILL PAY THEIR LEGAL